many fans expressed frustration with
Chris Pratt's casting as Mario in the
Super Mario Brothers movie and there are
still those who would prefer a different
voice actor had been selected
specifically Charles martinet he's the
actor who has voiced Mario Luigi Waluigi
and Wario in every major game since the
1990s hello I'm amario let's make a
pizza pie together while Martinez
certainly doesn't have as big a role in
the new movie as Pratt he does offer his
talents to two supporting characters a
character credited as Giuseppe seen
playing Jumpman in the pizzeria at the
start of the movie and briefly at the
end is voiced by Martin a in this role
he gets to put his own incomparable spin
on some classic Mario lines and sounds
capping off the movie with his iconic
wahoo
martinay also voices Mario and Luigi's
father while this second character
doesn't have as many recognizable Mario
sound bites it is clever and wholly
appropriate casting